[Music]  this is kombucha real kombucha that iced  tea you buy in those expensive bottles  fermented and sweetened it's good but  it's not kombucha  somewhere along the line the word was  lost in translation in japanese cha  means tea  and this is kombu this is the story of  the real kombucha  first the kombu  kombu is a type of seaweed and a staple  ingredient in japanese cuisine and  rishiri island off the northernmost tip  of japan has become known for the kombu  that grows here  zanichi kosaka is a third generation  fisherman  namake  foreign  [Music]  after kombu is harvested and dried it  can be used to make anything from soup  to salad to garnish but for our purposes  we're going to make kombucha  shiharu hirakawa is a shop owner selling  kombucha made from locally harvested  kombu  100  [Music]  sorry nope  but do you have any words for those  seeking real kombucha  is  [Music]